dans le vieux montréal comme dans le
reste du centre-ville tout est calme
presque désert il n'y a que quelques
piétons mais beaucoup de sans abri près
de l'accueil bonneau des sans abri comme
richard qui ne savent plus où aller
pris en otages pris complètement en
otage jr
ouais c'est quoi le notre monde va
s'écrouler par un petit virus
nous avons déclaré l'état d'urgence
local pour contrer la propagation de la
maladie
la ville de montréal met en place des
mesures pour venir en aide aux sans abri
deux sites de jours temporaires ont été
ouverts dans le centre ville et
l'objectif un film c'est un peu de
reproduire parce que vous savez que
plusieurs centres de jour qui sont
fermées dans les dernières dans les
derniers jours en fait ils se sont tous
fermés en rafale des tentes ont été
installées des bénévoles distribuent de
la nourriture dont des repas chauds pour
les sans abri qui craignent d'attraper
la maladie pour éviter la promiscuité
toussaint le meilleur moyen de le faire
c'est à l'extérieur en tentant le plus
possible de faire respecter aux gens les
mesures de distanciation social chez
montréal lui je sais que je mourrai pas
dans le centre ville depuis le début de
la crise tous les centres de jour pour
sans abri ont été fermés avec le virus
kiko présentement dans l'emplacement
dans le bassin où est-ce qu'on était on
respecte la distance sociale et ne
pouvait ne pouvait simplement pas être
respectée alors on a décidé de sortir de
la boîte puis du confort pour pouvoir
continuer à desservir la clientèle
ailleurs à montréal les citoyens
apprennent à vivre dans une ville
presque désert en état d'urgence
je pense que c'est une très bonne chose
oui ça permet d'assurer que l'on limite
finalement
la contamination qu'on puisse aplatir la
coupe et bien sûr s'assurer que les gens
soient en sécurité
j'ai peur que les personnes ne suivent
pas ce qu'il faut faire pour nous
protéger
la prochaine étape pour la métropole
pourrait être de fermer la ville de
confiner les résidents chez eux ici jean
philippe robillard radio canada montréal